hello welcome to my terraforming Master
strategy guide video series for the sake
of easiness we're just going to continue
from where we list the first video off
so we're just gonna start with tip
number 11. tip number 11 and 12 are
about colonies so if you're not playing
with colonies proceed to tip number 13.
tip number 11 buy colonies especially
Luna and Pluto the colony cards are
really good and probably at least in the
early game the best stand-up project in
the game is the standard project build a
colony for 17 Mega credits I will say
that the once in a blue moon pun
intended all colonies are bad for you
and you cannot use any of the resources
for anything after all the address that
at random in that case maybe don't buy
colonies but in 99 out of 100 games you
should at the very least have one Colony
often the best colony is Luna but other
kailanese can be very strong as well
depending on the game Pluto series
Triton Kalisto also up there but
honestly all of the colonies are really
good it really depends on the situation
like in the late game Mirana is also
really powerful you can make document
for all of these colonies to be honest
Pluto is the go-to colony if you have
money income going remember the
relationship between money and coming
Capital like we talked about in the
first video money income multiplied with
capital so you need a balance in both in
other words if you have very little
money income it's hard to spend 17 Mega
credits on just cards in this case Pluto
is not as powerful you could actually
make the argument that if you're really
desperate trying to get engine building
caps you could just try YOLO and just
build a colony in Pluto and try to dig
out some engine building cards this is
fair and although this europlate does
work sometimes generally speaking if you
have little to no money income then
Pluto simply dwarves in comparison to
some of the engine building colonies
like seros or Luna on the other hand if
you have a bunch of money income then
Pluto is excellent even better than Luna
in this case and speaking of Luna this
colony is just always solid like we
talked about in the first video if you
have the choice between buying a colony
and Luna and playing a mediocre card
Luna just wins every single time let me
try to explain it this way if Luna was a
card Luna effectively gives you sort of
kind of four Mega credit production two
for the placement bonus and two for the
colony bonus if people are flying there
every single generation however in
practice it's a little lower than this
because people are not actually visiting
Luna every single generation at least
not in the early game as people are
simply not set up to trade yet but as
soon as people do get the 3A energy
production to trade with or something
then Luna will pretty much get visited
every single generation almost maybe 80
of the time so placing Luna between
three or four Mega credit production is
pretty fair I think and this is not even
taken into account the amount of Mega
credit you actually get when you trade
here I'm only talking about the colony
bonus and the placement bonus so a
colony standard project costs 17 Mega
credits so imagine a card that you pay
three Mega credits to keep then the card
costs 14 Mega credits and it gives you
three to four Mega credit production
something like this would I buy this in
the first generation hell yeah this card
is basically Luna Luna is very good
let's compare that to some of the god
tier Mega credit production cards you
could get in the early game so space
hotels Luna exports acquired companies
all of these cars are better than Luna
but to be fair these cards are excellent
in the first generation especially space
hotels but this is kind of fair because
space hotels require you to have two
Earth tags and that's why space hotels
are so good and lunar exports is good
because it literally exporting from Luna
so even though this card has absolutely
nothing to do with Luna just having Luna
in the name makes this card good by
association that's how good Luna is so
if Luna gets visited every single
generation which means that Luna equals
4 Mega credit production then Luna
honestly can almost compete with all
these guard tier cards but even if we
said Luna to just three Mega credit
production then buying a colony in Luna
is nevertheless still a solid play so if
you have really good cards like these in
your opening hand a colony and Luna
might not even be needed however I I
think still if I have all of these
incredible cards in my opening hand I
still would consider buying a colony and
dune I might just play all of these
cards to begin with and then and build a
colony in Luna on generation 2 or 3
worth noting people actually don't
really trade in the first few
Generations usually it takes a few
Generations as the trade income is just
so bad to begin with and also takes a
few Generations before people get the
three energy production or something so
they can actually trade so by following
this logic it could actually make sense
that you just wait a little bit before
buying Luna if you have better engine
building cards like these in your hand
just be careful that the three available
slots on Luna doesn't get taken from you
before you have a chance to get in on
the action in the groups I've played
with it's actually pretty normal that
the three available slots on Luna just
get taken like immediately in the first
generation especially in four player
games if being in a four player game and
you're the one guy who doesn't get a
colony in Luna that sucks but let's say
you're in a group where none of your
opponents actually favor Luna so nobody
is building a colony Luna then Luna is
not as good because the trade income
won't rise as high which means that Luna
might not get visited every generation
in this case we're back to Luna only
being worth three Mega grip version I
will say I've played terraform mass and
maybe 10 different groups something like
this and it's only one of the groups
where literally no one put any value on
Luna except for me it was actually
really strange I had the only colony in
Luna I heard it all to myself so in this
case Luna isn't as good but even though
Luna is less powerful if there's only
one colony in Luna then it opens up the
possibility of getting a double Colony
or maybe even triple colony and doing a
video cards like research Colony or
spacebot colony in other words if you
get a double Colonial Luna you are over
the moon and getting a triple colony in
Luna is just out of this world almost
never happens but when it does it's
really good you can even say that it's a
play that eclipses all others All Things
Considered Luna is still really powerful
and you should seriously consider
building a colon in Luna in the first
generation every single game so the
standard project built a colony for 17
Mega credit it's actually good it
doesn't even have to be Luna it could be
in one of the others also reasonable and
if you have Colony cards it's even
better pretty much all of the cards this
is Colony somewhere and the text are
usually good especially in the early
game if you have several of these cards
and get just a little bit of colony
Synergy then it can be actually
incredibly good just to give you an
example here's the combo I showed you in
the first video I also have a whole
episode dedicated to reviewing project
cards tip number 11.5 a good solid play
I often make is to buy a colony as your
first action and then you spend three
energy to trade as your second action in
other words if you are considering
trading on a colony then you should
really consider to also build a colony
there before you trade and the reason
you want to do this in the same turn is
though that you don't risk your opponent
trading there instead of you or building
a colony there themselves as you've just
telegraphed like a madman that you
intended to trade here so build a colony
first and then trade immediately tip
number 11 if you're playing with
colonies get three energy production as
soon as possible it's hard to explain
but it is somehow just a lot cheaper to
spend three energy to trade than it is
to spend three Titanium or nine Mega
credit so glass half full if you want to
trade every single generation then a
preload card like power our generation
is just worth like nine Mega credit
production which is super good 9 Mega
credit production is the same as paying
9 Gold every single generation to trade
so buy this Logic power generation is
just the best preload in the game if
you're playing with colonies honestly I
have had games sometimes where just
straight up bought three energy
production as standard projects because
that's how much I value having three
energy production to trade with but this
is a bit extreme of course to spend 33
Mega credit like this so I wouldn't
recommend doing this too often but if I
intend to trade every single generation
then the 33 Mega credit I spent is sort
of worth 9 Mega credit production so
this is not completely awful that being
said preferably you do want cards that
give you energy production you can also
visit Europa to get energy that's a bit
cheaper because nine instead of 11 or
you can buy a colony on Callisto so tip
number 12.5 and this is a bit of a niche
scenario but if you have two space
fleets but only two energy production
then you can buy a colony in Callisto to
get your third end of pre-production and
then you can trade here with the first
spaceship every generation and then you
get a little bit of excess energy to
boot which will be turned into heatly
and worth noting your opponents cannot
really deny you this by flying to
Callisto themselves because when you
already have a colony there then you get
three energy so if they trade there
before you do then you're all of a
sudden you'll have six energy to trade
with with your two space fleets instead
of just one which is even better what
your opponents could do is to just build
a colony and Kalisto themselves so when
you do this trick they will also get
three energy but it is what it is tip
number 13 some things are better to do
at the beginning of a generation and
some things are better to do at the end
of a generation tip number 13 to 16 will
be discussed in a lot more detail in
episode 6 but here the shorter watered
down hit lands and which to be honest is
probably all you need not gonna lie
stuff to do as soon as possible in a
generation one Milestone and awards two
getting the last few available TR if a
parameter is about to close three
getting the best placement bonus on the
map four claiming a bonus on one of the
global parameters in the first episode
we talked about how this is really
important to protest these bonuses 5.
spending your plants before you get hit
by a comment like remember this guy yeah
this is why you want to start the
generation spending your plans before
these cards are just devastating you six
using Attack cards the cards with the
red border this one is not a
straightforward so I'll try to explain
it a little bit basically you should
steal and decrease opponent's stuff
while they still have something to steal
or decrease especially you want to burn
their plants before they have a chance
to spin them if your opponent has like
one energy production steal it for the
love of God before he has a chance to
spend that one energy production there
are some exceptions here regarding
reducing enemy production but I'll get
back to that in a second there's
actually also this psychological counter
argument here if you start the
generation hurting an opponent maybe
that opponent is going to use his attack
card on you as payback just something to
keep in mind some people enjoy
retaliation sadists and finally
number seven play effect cards giving
you X based on opponents y they could be
lie pets or it could be immigrant City
so this is stuff to do as soon as
possible in a generation now let's look
at stuff that's good to do as late as
possible in a generation one you want to
play cards and use action cards where
you get eggs and opponents why so this
is not like the same as pits and stuff
like this like we just talked about
those were like effects now what I'm
talking about here is stuff like Tull
station Galilean wave Station Martian
rails greenhouses aerospot tournament
and so on I'm probably forgetting some
of these media archives is also a good
one and as you go without saying that
cards like Martian rails aerospot
tournament and Mickey the archives the
cards just gives you Mega Credit Now
naturally there shouldn't technically be
your last action this would be like your
second to last action or something
because technically the last action
should then be to spend the mega credits
you get when you play these cards but
tell station however should literally be
your last action of the generation it's
like it physically hurts me when I see
someone playing tall station at the
start of generation like why would you
do that I'm too polite to say anything
but I really cringe and I Facebook that
I'm hurting inside like you literally
get additional potential value for free
if you wait for as long as possible
before playing these cards like tall
station so literally play toll station
or stuff like this at the very last
action of the generation or at least
until everyone else has passed you know
two making plays to set yourself up to
win a race at the start of the upcoming
generation like the surprise factor is
of course bigger if you wait until the
very last minute before you reveal your
master plan this also works even better
if you are the first player in the
upcoming generation three terraforming
with heat resources and action cards it
is technically correct to wait for as
long as possible before spending your
heat resources because increasing the
temperature scale might just be helping
your opponent and you want to wait for
as long as possible before potentially
helping your opponents I can only think
of three exceptions to this rule a you
can claim a bonus B the temperature
parameter is closing and you really want
to get the last few available Tia before
it closes completely and see you
yourself have a card with a temperature
requirement not quite being mid and
spending exactly your heat and
increasing the temperature is the last
bit you need in order to play that card
for decreasing an opponent's energy
production if they are using it for
something specific like trading or
powering action cards so if you see an
opponent who is using his energy
production for something specific then
you want to decrease their energy
production as late as possible to do the
most damage preferably after they've
already passed the generation so the
eagle-eyed viewer will have noticed that
I just told you to use a tech card as
soon as possible but here's the rule of
thumb if they have one energy production
remove it immediately but if you play
with colonies and they have three energy
production or if they are powering some
sort of card and they have four energy
production something like this then you
want to wait for as long as possible and
while we add it you can also make the
argument that you should just wait for
as long as possible before decreasing
enemy production in general simply
because this will mess up their
calculation a little bit but you know
this is minor things the most damage you
can do is definitely decreasing the
energy production exactly when they have
passed and they just oh I needed that
energy impression to trade or something
that's when you can do the most damage
also a very nice scenario here but
number five if your opponent has
predators and you have an animal cat
with no animals on it make the animal as
late as possible preferably after the
Predator guy targets another player and
eats their animal instead of yours or if
no one else has any animals maybe the
correct play is to just never create an
animal if you have zero animals that is
and then you can literally just watch
the Predator starve to death okay now
we're talking about really specific
examples but you get the pun I'm trying
to make it really does matter which
stuff you do at the start of a
generation and it really does matter
which stuff you're doing at the end of a
generation tip number 14 spend only one
action on your turn unless you have a
reason to spend two actions reasons why
it's generally better to only take one
action on your turn one your opponent
shows your hand before you do after you
see what they are doing you might make a
different play two it essentially gives
you more action in a row which you can
use to do all kinds of things and three
if you are starting the upcoming
generation then you'll have even more
actions in a row so why is it better to
have many actions in a row you can
surprise claim a milestone you can claim
bonuses without being contested and most
importantly things are like under your
control lots of scenarios will benefit
you if your opponent shows their hand
before you do so when you're starting
the upcoming generation you should use
this to your advantage and also you
should be mindful of the player who is
starting the upcoming generation because
maybe that guy also watched the Boneless
strategy guide in YouTube so here's
where it gets a bit tricky because there
are some exceptions to this one action
per turn rule in general so when is it
better to actually spend two actions on
your turn so number one the players
around the table are playing casually
and you haven't maybe unspoken rule of
taking two actions on your turn to avoid
slow playing this is sometimes the case
depending on which group you play in and
this is completely Fair also if you're
just playing a casual game on the mass
app on real life to be honest attempt to
take two actions on my turn quite often
it is quite normal as long as you know
that it is technically correct to only
take one action on your turn most of the
time because in a lot of situations it
really can't make a difference that
being said there are also situations
where it's correct to take two actions
on your turn for example number two
there could be some sort of race going
on Races could be milestones and awards
the last few are available Tia the
parameters about to close getting the
best placement bonus on the map or maybe
a bonus on the global parameter is like
only two actions away then of course you
want to grab that number three setting
yourself up to an even better placement
bonus on the map like if you place water
and then as your second action you place
something next to the water in this case
it also makes sense to take two actions
on a turn and four build a colony is
your first action and trade as your
second action we already talked about
this and number five playing around
stuff like energy tapping and power
supply Consortium so what you do is as
the first action you create your energy
production and then as your second
action you spin the energy production
immediately and number six is once again
this guy so number six acquiring
plans and then building a Greenery so
this is how you play around asteroid so
once again you spend your first action
getting the last plans you need and then
as your second action you make a
Greenery and seven if possible consider
spending your mega credit steel and
titanium immediately to play around like
sabotage aerators hydrators something
like this but this is like a little less
important but sometimes it does come
into play sometimes it's just nice to
just spend all your mega credit at once
if like if this is the plan you have on
this generation why not just do it
immediately so I know that this is a lot
of information at once but here's the
point the point is you want to spend one
action on your turn this should like be
second nature to you if you do spend two
actions in your turn you must have a
reason for doing so that being said like
we talked about and as long as you know
that there's this technically the
correct way to do it then well you can
still just play casually and take two
actions on your turn it's fine it really
depends on how much you want to win and
how the players around the table feel
about this tip number 14.5 in the last
generation is it is extra important to
only take one action on your turn the
reason why this is important is first of
all well what if it's not really the
last generation perhaps your opponent is
surprised closing the game or perhaps he
is surprised not closing the game which
can be equally as devastating and two
slow playing is crucial for fighting for
Wards if for example the minor award has
been started it's really nice to know
how much you need to win their award and
how much titanium you can actually
afford to spend on Joven amplifiers and
stuff like this number three if you pass
the generation before your opponents
then they might burn your plans or
decrease your plane production then I
knew that plus one Greenery from this
run like remember this guy the bird
person this guy that just intentionally
really Waits until you pass the last
generation and then it just removes your
plans of plan production preventing you
from getting the plus one Greenery it's
really annoying if you are actually this
bird person yourself brings us to number
four you should wait for as long as
possible before removing opponent's plan
production especially in the last
generation basically all of these
annoying little mind games they just
work a lot better if you're the last one
to pass the last generation so these are
the reasons why it's especially
important to only take one action on
your turn in the last generation in
other words you shall not pass the last
generation before your opponent if
possible are there exceptions when it
comes to the last iteration as well yes
here they are when is it better to spend
two actions on your turn in the last
iteration number one you're in a rush to
start the last award two you're in a
rush to get the last bit of available TR
before the game closes three you want
the good placement bonus or actually if
it's one of those games where the map is
just filling up like crazy then maybe
you just want a placement bonus like it
sometimes happens that there are only
maybe one good CD spot left or something
like this in this case it's of course
also a race to get the last good
placement bonus on the map tip number 15
card sequence do not play a card until
you need the card for something so
before we talk about this I should just
real quick cover my bases we talked
about this in the first video but
naturally engine builder cards should be
played in the early to mid game because
like we talked about in the early game
you need money income and you should
start grabbing VP when they're like four
generations left and pure VP should be
played in the last generation Jovian
amplifier should also usually be played
in the last generation except for I O
mining Industries there are actually a
few exceptions when it comes to driving
amplifier we will look at these in the
next video but generally speaking this
is the correct way to go the reason why
IO mining Industries is good to play
early on is because it gives you a ton
of engine two titanium production and
two Mega credit production very good for
building engine so if you want to you
can actually do it like this I I do this
to some extent but you can literally
just make a pile with late game cards
and play them in the last few
Generations it's very good to divide
your cards like this either have them in
your hand on the table or something so
you have some idea of which card you
want to play Here and Now and which card
you really don't want to play until the
late game so here are some reasons why
some nuts are just better to be played
later on first of all Mega credit is
worth more in the early game compared to
the same amount of Mega Credit in the
late game and two perhaps you pick up
some discount cards during the game in
other words why would you play
Interstellar Colony ship in Generation 3
when you could have played a 4 Mega
credit cheaper in the last generation
because you picked up let's say Earth
Cannibal and space station number three
in addition to becoming cheaper some
cards can actually also become worth
more if you played later in the next tip
I will elaborate a lot more on this
specific concept number four you also
don't want to show your hand until you
have to like if you're playing draft
your opponents might pass your signs
tags a green tags because they don't
know you have let's say venusian animals
if they know they have this card played
then they might not give you Science
Tech right so getting back to the point
here you do not want to play a card
until you need it for something you want
to play colonizer training camp as late
as possible but still within the max 5
oxygen requirement so probably you want
to to play this when the oxygen is
around four or five something like this
don't play discount cards before you
need the discount effect don't play
ecological Zone and decomposers until
you plan on playing Green text do not
play herbivores until you plan on making
some greeneries well okay this one is a
bit different because you also decrease
enemy playing production so if you
really want to be a sadist you can play
it a little sooner which I can get
behind don't play venusian Animals
before you plan on playing science text
or benefit from having animals in some
way could be like meat industry so it
could be large Convoy although I will
say that in most situations large Convoy
is actually also better to play in the
late game could also be Miranda or maybe
you just need the science tag to play
something nice like enter gravity
technology for example so as a rule do
not play a card until you have a clear
reason to actually play the card if the
reason is purely Victory point then you
should play the card in the last
generation instead of what you're doing
tip number 16 some cards are potentially
worth more when played later on this can
be a number of different things but the
biggest examples that comes to mind is
like science text or green text so
Science Tech will increase in value if
you pick up like Mars University Olympus
conference or venusian animals green
text will increase in value if you pick
up like viral enhancers meat Industries
decomposers ecological Zone and so on
this is why I sometimes hold on to cards
like research in the hope that I will
during the game pick up stuff like
Olympus conference Mass university
venusian animals so basically you do
have to make an assessment do you want
to play research now or do you want to
gamble in the hope you could get extra
value from playing it later on what I do
is I probably hold on to it for as long
as possible until I run out of good
plays to make if I'm running low on
cards or if the cards in my hand just
very bad to play right now then I might
consider to just bring research now but
holding on to science cards in order to
play them later can be really good and
remember research has two science tags
naturally it depends what the science
tag actually does for you like if you
need to play it now of course just play
now green tags are another example of
cards that just might increase in value
the longer you hold on to it this is why
I considered a deadly sin to play
Advanced ecosystem before the last
generation so firstly this card has
literally only VP on it and secondly if
you played earlier you might be missing
out on some of the free VP you get from
Green text like these cards here and to
be honest this could be a lot of points
we're talking about all of a sudden
Advanced ecosystem is just worth three
plans and five victory points instead of
only three victory points other cards
also gets better over time not because
of their tags but because of what they
do when you play it so I'm talking about
these cards here there are probably more
of these that I'm forgetting so you
might be thinking well you should just
always wait for as long as possible
before playing these cards and yeah
usually that's correct but it's not
always completely correct because
remember there's also this aspect of
Mega credit being worth more in the
early game compared to the late game
could be that you just desperately need
the mega credit right now in order to
make a good play it could also be that
you need the science tag from molecular
printing to play anti-gravity technology
or I need the Earth tag from media
archives to play cartel or something
like this could also be you need the
plans from greenhouses to get the bonus
on the oxygen scale so in certain
situations it's better to play this cars
a little bit sooner but as a rule you
want to play these as late as possible
unless you have a good reason there are
many examples to be honest like resource
amplifiers or robotic Workforce could
also get better over time and then it
gets a little bit tricky once again
because production is something you
really want to get earlier on which
leads me to tip number 17 play to
maximize amplifying cards like insects
cartel and satellite these cards are
very very good like often people feel
that the reason they lost a game of
terraforming Mars is because the other
guy got plus one Milestone more than me
or they got one more Joven amplifier
than me something like this but I would
make the argument that often these
resource amplifiers are even more
impactful than Joven amplifier people
just don't think about it this way
because they can't really picture how
many VP playing satellites actually
ended up giving like we mentioned in the
first video all of these amplifying
cards are by Nature situational however
most of them are just so aggressively
stated that they're just good in most
games and even in a few games they're
just stupidly overpowered and they will
literally win you the game this is why I
really have to pay attention to these
cars in your games so if you have some
sort of amplifying card like insects or
cartel or satellites and naturally you
want to play to maximize the effect
meaning that if you play cartel of
course you for the most part want to
play all the Earth attacks before you
play it within recent and when I say
within reason just to give you an
example you probably don't want to play
terraforming Ganymede just so you can
get plus one Mega credit production from
satellites it's not always the case
however because there's also this
element of this sooner you get it down
the better because remember production
is better the earlier you get it so it's
kind of a balancing act sometimes it's
better to play cartel with five Earth
tags in generation 4 than it is to play
cartel with seven Earth tag in
generation 6. it really depends on a lot
of things it depends on how long the
game is gonna be it depends if you had a
nice alternative play to make instead of
doing the five Earth Tech cartel and if
I had a card like insects in my hand I
just keep a bunch of plant production
tags in my hand then I still focus on
money and common stuff but then when the
six oxygen requirement of insects have
been met then I'll just play all the
plant tags and then I just slam down
insects sometimes you can of course also
play the plant tags a bit sooner if you
have some nice modern income going
if you're thinking which of these cards
are the strongest it's very hard to
determine as all of these cards are by
Nature very situational that being said
I'm still willing to say that like Luna
mining cartel Miranda Resort tall
station satellites insects are istia
cars with a good I admit Miranda Resort
is a little bit expensive when it comes
to building your engine but nevertheless
the car itself comes with a dual intake
it's pretty cheap so worst case scenario
you just played in the late game and
feel fine about it tall station and
Galilean weigh station are better than
more players are actually in the game
but even in two player games you can get
quite nice value from these cards it's
just more situational in two player
games I also consider the warning I go
to Luna metropolis and geropolis but for
the purpose of engine building they're
just very expensive so you really have
to think twice before deciding to build
your engine using these cards that being
said I have won a bunch of games on the
back of a god like geropolis like in the
right circumstance this card is
absolutely disgusting speaking of cards
that can be very expensive but can give
you a ton of Mega credit production we
also got interplanetary trade and sulfur
experts kind of the same story with
these cards I almost didn't put sulfur
exports on the left with this sort of
bad cards but not really but it just
feels like it is a bit expensive for
what it gives you sibilance is also a
good car that somebody is going for
cities but what really brings this card
down for me is the five oxygen
requirement I mean that is rough
especially considering that the mega
credit production is better in the early
game and in my experience oxygen is
actually the last parameter to move in
the early game so this card can be a
little bit awkward and even if you
yourself are going for cities you still
kinda don't want to keep this card in
your opening hand because it just might
take too long before you reach the five
oxygen requirement but the redeeming
facts of this car is that it also has
one Victory Point attached to it so
there is a point in the mid game where
you play this card and you feel really
good about it and to be fair in certain
games where you just top deck zebulance
at just the right time then this card
could give you a lot of value worms we
talked about in the first video I don't
like worms so even though the resource
amplifiers generally are really good
also kpi out for cars that just straight
up gives you Mega credit so we're back
to these hey so do not underestimate
these cards if you do the math these
cards just might give you just as much
or maybe even more than some of the mega
credit production amplifiers it's just
it doesn't look as shiny right when you
see oh cartel 5 Mega credit production
ah I want this once again these cards
are of course also situational but
generally speaking I just feel like this
research amplifiers and also these cards
generally speaking they're good I should
also quickly mention robotic Workforce
like if you combo this card with for
example medical lab or giropolis like
seriously I've had games where my entire
game plan was just to make the biggest
air up police the world I've ever seen
and then following that up with an
equally big robotic Workforce tip number
18 play the Good cards taking into
account the number of players in the
game first of all it goes without saying
that you just want to play the best
cards naturally terraform mass is a
pretty well balanced game I think
honestly but there's still some cards
that are better and some cards that are
worse and recognizing the good cards
from the bad cars is an acquired skill
that comes from Intuition or experience
so you can just try to math your way out
of it like I mentioned in the first
video just instinctively I know that
indentured workers and lunar exports are
Keepers in my opening hand whereas error
breaks ammonia asteroid and Interstellar
Colony ship are not Keepers I'll talk
more about evaluating cards in general
in episode 8 but right now what I really
want to talk about is the good card and
the bad cards considering how many
players are in the game I don't think a
lot of players realizes this but some
cards are simply better in two player
games whereas other cards are simply
better in five player games and once
again a lot of this comes down to the
fact that two-player games are longer in
terms of generations where five player
games are shorter in terms of
generations in two player games the
following types of cards are very good
and you should consider playing these
cards one Attack cards cards with a red
border these are just some examples and
of course keep in mind that hackers are
just generally also better than the
early game game because it comes with
make a credit production but basically
almost all of the Attack cards are just
really effective in two-player games as
you're damaging your one opponent more
than the cost you actually pay to play
the card but then you might be thinking
well you're also hurting an opponent if
you're playing a five player game but
the difference is that in a five player
game you're only attacking 25 of your
opponents whereas in a two-player games
you're hurting 100 of your opponents
with Attack cards it's really just the
one opponent but you get what I mean on
top of that if you use an attack guard
on an opponent in a five player game you
also put a Target on your back and that
player will likely retaliate on you
rather than spending their Attack cards
on another player in two player games
Attack cards will always hit you like no
matter what you do you can't there's no
one else Two Greedy cars also tend to be
better in two player games because
two-player games are longer in terms of
generations compared to a 5 player game
which means that you can get away with
more greed so the best examples I can
give you is like AI central
interplanetary trade or anti-gravity
technology these are extremely greedy
cars and they are very good in two
player games but the five player games
maybe not so much I will say that if you
can get away with it and play them
pretty fast these cards are of course
also very good in five player games just
know that these cards come with a lot
more risk in five player games AI
Central is straight up one of the best
cards in the game in a two-player game
but in a five player game it might be
too greedy because AI Central is
expensive it costs 21 Mega credit is one
energy production and it requires three
science texts and before you look around
suddenly to spend the first sixth
generation creating engine playing
science tags and then playing AI Central
and then the game is just over because
you're playing a trash five-back game
and then you lose horribly because you
haven't had time to make the transition
from greedy engine to point graphic this
is what I mean when I say you should be
careful of greedy cars and five player
games but in two player games AI Central
is one of the best cards it's kind of
the same story with interplanetary trade
this cards can also be very strong but
it kind of takes a few generations to
play all the different tags in order to
make this card worth it and also the
card itself is very expensive 27 Mega
credit so you could also walk into the
same trap of just making engine for
sixth generation then you finally play
interplanetary trade and then the game
is over in seven generations and
the technology kind of the same thing it
takes a while to set up the proper
science text Synergy other examples of
cards that are better in two player
games are simply cat draw cards for
exactly the same reasons as we talked
about card draw cards are just super
good in two-player games the thing is
the game that lasts for many generations
like 13 or 14 or something like this the
best strategy in these games are just
the car strategy and as we've talked
about usually the longer games in terms
of generations are two player games so
these are the types of cards that are
just very good in two player games but
let's talk about five player games the
following types of cars are very good in
five player games and should be played
most of the time one cards that gives
you something based on opponent's tags
or your opponent's floaters or something
like this I'm talking tall station
Quantum Communications Galilean weigh
station thasis Poseidon just to give you
some examples it's not in every game
that these cards are just broken in five
player games naturally you still have to
actually count your opponent's tags and
so on once again these cards are
situational I should point out that just
because you have four opponents it
doesn't mean that you get four times the
value from tall stage and it's not quite
like this because two players in a two
player game usually have a lot more
cards played than the people in a five
player game that being said there's no
doubt on my mind that statistically
these cards are usually better in five
player games like literally often the
best card on the game in five player
games is tall station it's insane in
five player games it can be at least two
cities energetic cards to a lesser
extent like in The Same Spirit you could
also argue that thuses and City Synergy
cards in general are slightly better
than 5 play games than two player games
however this one is not as clear I think
because in two player games sometimes
there are more cities than there would
be in a 5 play games but once again
statistically I think these are still
slightly better in five player games and
three cards that gives you terraform
rating like seriously in five play games
people just grab traster than toilet
paper doing a pandemic like it's crazy
the thing is terraform rating gives you
both Mega credits and the VP and you
need both pretty quickly in the event
that you'll be playing a short games
with few new generations terraform
rating is also good in two player games
but I kind of feel like they are extra
important in five player games so these
are the types of cards that generally
speaking are better in five player games
tip number 19 don't be afraid to use
standard projects but use them wisely
standard projects are there to be used
the way the game works is that cards are
more efficient compared to standard
projects however you don't always have
the right card you need for the
situation most of these standard
projects are sort of weak so you kind of
need to have a clear purpose in mind
when playing them the trick is to know
exactly when standard projects are worth
it so here are the Boneless guide to
using standard projects I mean at this
point why the hell not first of all it
goes without saying that standard
projects gets a lot better if you have
standard technology especially when you
play it with the colonies expansion but
let's assume you do not have this card
in that case when is it good to actually
make standard projects sell patterns you
should sell bad cards but only the
second you need that one Mega credit to
buy something and even if you are buying
a car for 3 Mega credit and then you
regret it happens to the best of us
there's no shame in selling that card
again from one maker Grid it's better
than just never using it right so the
reason you want to hold on to your cards
until you actually need that one Mega
credit is that the debt card on your
hand actually might end up being
worthwhile perhaps you pick up a lot of
discount cards a green tax energy or you
just pick up a card that requires the
tag of the card you intend on selling or
something like this it could also be
that you simply need cards in your hand
even the debt cards just so you have
something to cycle it could be Pluto
Colony bonus it could be Mars University
or sponsored Academy's power plant only
thing I'll say about this standard
project is if you need it you need it it
is quite expensive for 11 Mega credits
but it is something you buy in a lot of
games if you have to also like we talked
about earlier if you're playing with
colonies you desperately need three
energy production but buying three power
plants like I said is a bit extreme more
realistically you get maybe two energy
production from preloads or cards or
something and in that case it's entirely
reasonable to just buy the last energy
production you need so you can trade in
fact this would be a good play and once
again if you are playing with colonies
you can also get energy a little cheaper
by trading on Europa then we got
asteroid for 14 Mega credits and then we
got the Venus standard project ass
grabbing for 15 Mega credits these two
are very similar I think which is why I
bundled them together both of them sucks
man
like these should only be played if you
have a really clear purpose in mind so
like we talked about a TRS roughly with
eight Mega credits so buying asteroid is
overpaying by 6 and air scrapping is
overpaying by seven I can think of only
three scenarios where you actually buy
this trash so let's start with asteroid
never buy this unless one you're close
to a bonus if you can grab the water
placement bonus off of this then it is
worth it the heat production bonus is
sometimes worth it if you're desperate I
guess like I mean if I hit production in
the early game is worth 5 Mega credits
and a TS with eight that's only 13 and
the standard project costs 14 so like
minus one still it's it's not that good
but sometimes you're desperate and
there's also this aspect of you don't
want to give the bonus to your opponent
and two you need to close the game in
the previous video in tip number eight
we talked about the value of actually
closing the game early to punish the
greedy player at the start of the game
this standard project is just way too
expensive but maybe in the last
generation maybe the last two
generations if you need like three more
steps to close the game for fine I
actually do this sometimes it might just
be something you have to do in order to
win the game and three you have a card
in your hand with a temperature
requirement it has to be a really good
card to Warrant this terrible asteroid
standard project like farming or trees
or fish or something maybe tuned or
farming but otherwise it is simply not
worth it air scrubbing is pretty much
the same it will have to be like the
venusian animals or the terraform rating
bonus on the Venus scale before you even
consider buying this trash maybe each
time mining I don't know you get the
point I should probably Gather By Now I
consider these two standard projects the
worst standard projects in the game then
we got the aquifier if we do the math
this standard project is also a bit
underwhelming it cost 18 gives a TR with
8 and a placement bonus worth let's be
generous and say four so that's 12 so if
you buy it for 18 then it's like -6 in
value so it's not good however even
though the math is also bad on this one
there are a number of situations where I
will actually buy a water first of all
remember that there are only nine Waters
to be placed on mass and honestly a few
of those Waters usually go already in
the first generation so this means that
if you have a card with water
requirement then it can be okay to maybe
like buy one of these or maybe two of
these in order to satisfy the
requirement of the card but the aquifer
standard project is really expensive so
once again it will have to be the really
good card to Warrant such desperation
pretty much has to be like kelp farming
or Penguins capital or LT are also worth
mentioning but it's almost not worth it
and number two could also be that you
have some sort of water Synergy going on
it could be like Neptune or Arctic algae
three or again you want to close the
game and water is the last parameter to
close you can play the water to close
the game four you can get like an epic
water placement bonus what I mean
specifically is that if you pay the 18
Mega credits and buy water as your first
action then as your second action you
can do something nice next to the water
you just place this is the redeeming
facts of water is that you have two
actions so you can bend your first
action placing the water and your second
action and placing something next to the
water okay now we get to the slightly
better standard projects let's talk
about greeneries and cities once again
just to get it out of the way if oxygen
is the last parameter to close and you
want to close the game then naturally
planned ingredients makes sense and also
if the oxygen parameter is about to
close maybe you want the last few
available TR on the oxygen scale or
maybe you can get a temperature bonus on
the oxygen scale then maybe it's worth
making Greenery to do this could also be
that it has some cars with high oxygen
requirements could be birds or insects
or sibilants so we kind of already
talked about this but here's where
greeneries and cities are different five
you can make cities and greeneries in
the mid to late game to get victory
points in the late game it's actually
pretty cost effective to have a few
cities and build greeners around them
like we mentioned in the previous video
greeneries are like worth approximately
three victory points in the late game if
you play them next to your cities if you
place the next to two of your cities
greeneries could be with four victory
points and so on and to be honest this
is not bad for 23 Mega credits in the
late game not to mention that they also
get the placement bonuses so truth be
told in the late game game your cards
actually have to be pretty good to
compete with this like we mentioned in
the previous video you really have to do
the math and figure out is it better to
play my cards or as a player to just
keep spamming cities and greeneries in
the late game so standard project series
and standard greeneries are not good for
engine building but there is a very nice
way to get victory points this is why
it's better to play these standard
projects in the last half of the game
the exception of course is if you have a
bunch of cities energetic cards then
what you can do is just to place a bunch
of cities early on and build your engine
this way but to be clear it has to be
some of the really good City Synergy
cards to actually warrant this strategy
I'm talking pretty much like immigrant
City Martian rails for thesis like I
think you have to have one of these you
probably also need a little bit extra it
could be like pets Rover construction
standard technology as epileans or
something like this we'll talk more
about the city strategy in the next
video but the point here is that
standard cities and greeneries is stuff
you want to look at in the mid to late
game because they are mainly a way to
get victory points and the only Only
Exception here is if you have six cities
energetic cards then you can also build
your engine with cities then if we're
playing with colonies the last standard
projects is to build a colony for 17
Mega credits we talked about it earlier
in my opinion this very good in the
early game you just have to do the math
to assess if it's better to actually
just build the colony for 17 or it's
better to play one of the cards in your
hand remember that the card itself costs
three Mega credits just for the patent
so when you kind of want to compare it
so the colony costs 14 and not 17. so
when you look at it this way often the
best play is to just build a colony on
Sirius or luna or something and then
when you get your engine up and running
Pluto is also really good tip number 20
don't keep cards in your opening hand
that has a crazy requirement unless
so the last thing I want to mention
today is for new players mostly and that
is just be careful don't keep cards on
your hand that has some sort of crazy
requirement like birds or trees or lake
Mariners or open City I would literally
never keep these cars in my opening hand
unless you have like the ecology experts
preloads and trees or something but you
know almost never I will keep these
cards in my opening hand so kelp farming
is like a car might consider keeping
it's almost sort of worth it because
there are so few steps when it comes to
water but in my opening hand I probably
still wouldn't keep this we could also
take this step further and say that you
should never keep a card you're not
planning to play this generation and
while this is a good tip for beginners
it doesn't really reflect the whole
truth the really good players actually
do keep a lot of late game cards in
their hand it's just you have to know
when to do it so there's no really
correct answer on this one this is a lot
of gray area so all I can do is just
share my thoughts on this so I would put
it like this in the early game only keep
mid to late game cards if one your
economy is strong enough to pay the
three Mega credit pattern without
tanking your engine if you have a bad
engine and then you start buying late
game cards or keeping them in your hands
then they're like dead cards forever and
then you might just be drowning yourself
two of the card benefits you a lot when
you then finally do play it Jovian
amplifiers is a good example just know
that the cards you're buying in the
early game and not playing they are not
actually worth three Mega credits for
the pattern three Mega credits in the
early game is worth more than three Mega
trades in the late game because in the
early game you're like investing these
three Mega credits on everything cool
and then in the late game it might be
worth maybe more like 10 megagrams so if
you feel like the card is worth more
than the mega credits you stand to lose
by buying it so early then you should
keep it and to be honest when I play
terrible Mass I actually do tend to keep
a lot of cards that become powerful
later I actually watched some of my
replays recently because I intend to do
some commentary of replays where I
played the online Mass app just to give
you some examples I had a 264 games
where I get insects in ecological Zone
all already in generation 2 but in this
game I had really nice engine building
cars also so I felt like I could
definitely get away with it I don't know
how many victory points these cards
ended up giving me but it was a ton an
absolute ton but then recently I had a
278 game in this game I actually didn't
buy any late game cards in the early
game but I think that's more because
they didn't really present themselves to
me so in this game the latest I bought
like a mid to late game cars I think
that would be decomposers but that was
on generation eight so this is
definitely not the early game anymore I
definitely would have also bought
Victory Point generating cars like
ecological Zone if I had seen them it
kinda illustrates my point that there's
no real clear answer to this one if you
want to watch these games with my
commentary this should be on my channel
already it should be episode 16 I think
examples of leaking cups you might want
to keep early so we talked a little bit
about this but first of all Jovian
amplifiers I feel like a lot of players
just agree that these cards can generate
an absolute bunch of victory points in
the late game which means that they are
probably worth to keep a lot other times
I don't always keep these in the early
game it also depends I think I would
always keep iron mining industry in the
early game it's just too good to pass up
gives you a lot of engine gives you a
lot of VP in the late game others
examples of cards you might want to keep
could also be these juicy science text
cards like like anti-gravity technology
AR Central Quantum extractor Mass
converter once again this would also
depend on how many cyan tags I have in
my hand and if my economy can handle
potential dead cars in my hand and stuff
like this because keeping some of these
cards I just mentioned is essentially a
gamble because I cannot know if I will
actually get the last science text I
need to actually play this it could also
be some of the good planned production
cards it could be like ecology research
nitrophilic moss and maybe if you have
like let's say two plant tags in your
hand or something then I would seriously
also consider keeping insects or
nitrogen-rich asteroid others examples
of cards I might keep in the early game
could be some of the Green Tech
amplifiers maybe not in my opening hand
but still pretty early on I would
seriously consider even these these are
very good so these are just examples of
cards I might want to keep early on in
my games there's really no clear answer
to this one it just comes down to
intuition and comes down to can your
economy actually handle it also comes
down to the fact that you shouldn't keep
cards you can't play it unless you have
a very good reason to keep them or maybe
you're just a reckless Gambler in that
case you're allowed bonus tip number one
if you play Draft hit drafting is a
thing be very careful what you give to
your opponents that's basically what
hate drafting means it is of course
better to focus on the cards that will
help you the most but if none of the
available cards are important then you
can choose the job in tag just that the
other guy doesn't get the job intake or
you can keep immigrant City just to the
city guy doesn't get immigrant City and
so on bonus tip 1.5 Synergy play all the
cards that synergizes with each other
you should always look for Synergy when
playing terraforming Mars or in real
life I guess bonus tip 1.5 a watch
episode 4 on my terraforming Mouse video
series where I talk about Synergy bonus
tip 1.7 focus on playing the strong
cards and for the the most part ignore
the bad cards bonus tip
1.9 point Pi Point Apple watch episode 8
of my video series where I read most of
the cards from estia to trash year in
other words feel free to check out these
other videos if you feel like it I kind
of Promise all of them are available on
my channel yet but sooner or later I
think all of these will be in my channel
there's a link to the playlist in the
description as you probably guessed by
now this video series will probably take
longer to watch than actually sitting
down and playing probably maybe in
several games of terraforming Mars
yourself which is a long time so if you
want to see some gameplay instead you
can check out video 16 to 19 where I do
commented playthroughs to be honest I
don't really care about high scores and
terraforming masks I don't think anybody
really does but that being said the 278
game is probably the highest scoring
game you will ever see on YouTube
especially considering this is like the
online app where it only comes with
vanilla and Prelude generally you can
achieve higher scores if you get more
expansions like if you play with
colonies and preludes three 300 is
definitely within reach if you have any
other tips then the tips are mentioned
here or if you agree or disagree with
anything feel free to mention in the
comments I'm game discussing all of this
with you also if you know of any other
terraform Master strategy guides then
feel free to also write that in the
comments then I will add it to the
description like if you want to I'm
serious you can just shamelessly promote
your own terrifying mask content I
really don't buy it I welcome the idea
of this being the place from which you
can find all the terraforming Mars guys
and so on I purposely didn't watch or
read any other tale from your mascot
before making my own because I thought
it would be more fun to share my own
view of the game rather than just
repeating what other wise men have said
but now that I have made this guide I'll
happily watch some of the other stuff
you sent me probably I missed something
and then in the very likely event that I
actually learned something new I would
talk about it in episode 10 called
feedback because this is a video I
haven't made yet thank you so much to
fuxilios and the stronghold games for
making my favorite board game this game
came out in 2006 team I think it says a
lot about this board game that so many
players are still playing it like years
later and it also says a lot about the
game that a guy like me just spent three
months of his life making this strategy
guide like nobody really asked for I
think you speak to how good the game is
of maybe I'm just a weird person